Trump's main advisor at the Aziz
campaign manager Jason Miller he's the
actual senior advisor Jason Miller went
on TV and he was asked whether Trump is
actually going to debate uh and here was
his answer
what is going to be the deciding factor
on whether president Trump does or does
not participate in the debates
great question at the moment president
Trump has indicated that he's unlikely
to participate at least in the first two
debates he's up by 30 40 and even new
polling shows he's up by almost 50
percent in certain places it really
wouldn't make much sense for him to go
and debate right now with a bunch of
folks who are down at three four and
five percent even Rhonda Sanctus who's a
second place candidate in the race
currently is at least 20 30 or 40 points
behind and so ultimately president Trump
will make a decision as we get closer he
has not said anything definitive one way
or the other I'm not expecting him to
participate though the fact that the
spokesman can't even say DeSantis his
name probably I'm just so sick of that
and I think more and more people
are but okay they're just going to do
that that's fine uh but Andrew this idea
that just because you're so far ahead
now National polls also don't mean
anything because you have to win
primaries not National polls but let's
say it's all legit and he is up by all
those numbers to me that does not excuse
you not going to debates if we are ever
going to get out of the lunacy that that
Spencer was just talking about we have
to be able to debate ideas and if you're
up by a ton you should be able to debate
them confidently so I think it's going
to be a major hit for him if he dips out
of these two debates what do you think I
think it's going to be a hit the balance
you always have to play is that if
you're that far ahead you have nothing
to win in a debate you can only lose in
a debate because he's so far ahead the
other side of that balance is that you
look like a wimp and you look like you
can't participate especially afterwards
when he comes out and starts calling
people names and starts you know
refuting their points and everybody says
well why didn't you show up and do that
to their faces why do it behind their
back Trump has still got a bit of Teflon
on him he sinks solo the name calling
and the idea that you know people are
losers and all this kind of stuff that
comes out of his mouth that to me people
do not understand how off-putting that
is to a large swath of Voters it is why
he lost he did not lose because martians
took the machines and changed the votes
he lost because he's a rude boorish man
who treats people badly even when they
work for him and that comes back to bite
you and it came back to bite him and I
think you know at some point at some
point people look at that and turn away
but so far he's just been golden and the
reason for that is because that's who he
plays on TV so everybody already knows
who he is and thinks that's just Trump
but at some point yeah you hope people
come back to reality instead of reality
TV by the way Andrew I I try to give you
credit on this one every time you're on
the show I think it's worth mentioning
again that we were together at the daily
wire uh Studios on the night of the
Trump election with Ben and Jeremy and
the whole crew and you said something
that really framed those first few years
of the presidency for me and ultimately
got me to be a trump supporter I think
in a certain respect because you said on
that night when the thing happened that
nobody thought Could Happen Trump became
president you said wow only in this
country can that sort of thing happen
and that's a beautiful thing that we
have in America because in most
countries the thing that you don't think
can happen can't happen and that's the
problem
thank you